italia cae una vez más en la
inestabilidad con una nueva crisis
política después de la dimisión del jefe
del gobierno mario draghi este jueves
como consecuencia de un voto en el
parlamento italiano durante el cual los
senadores del movimiento cinco estrellas
no votaron la confianza al gobierno y
esto a pesar de ser uno de los partidos
miembros de la coalición gubernamental
en días pasados draghi había advertido
que no está dispuesto a dirigir un
gobierno sin el pleno apoyo del
movimiento cinco estrellas algo que
repitió este jueves en un comunicado en
el cual considera que después de este
voto la alianza de unión nacional que
sostenía el gobierno dejó de existir sin
embargo frente a esta situación el
presidente italiano sergio mataré la
decidió no aceptar en la renuncia de
mario draghi y le solicito que trate de
encontrar una nueva mayoría en el
parlamento italiano que le permita
continuar con su mandato para esto mario
draghi debería pronunciar un discurso
ante el parlamento italiano el próximo
miércoles